we should probably get started just so
that we can end on time I'm Joe Nash and
I'm taking bill Hirsch's plates today
because he's out of state we have a very
special presentation on a Monday which
is very unusual but it's a good way to
start the week we have Jay in Moston who
is here from Massachusetts and Russ ha
grave here from Oregon talking about
technology policy in motion now dr.
Himelstein is a professor family
medicine and community health and many
other things as you can see on here he
holds a number of exalted roles and when
I checked on the website this morning I
saw you had two masters degrees yes one
in public health and one in physiology
from the Harvard School of Public Health
and rust may be known to some of you
because he is here in Oregon he is the
technology advisor and senior you
hundred see it again I checked on the
website and there were many titles there
so I know that they're extremely
qualified to talk to us about health
insurance exchange I keep wanting to say
health information exchange and I
wondered about the acronyms you know we
say hie and I thought there's another
hie it's a chai X that's how they
differentiate it so I learned something
this morning when I was checking things
out and I'll turn this over now to Jay
who's going to start yeah well thank you
i think is this mike live ok good well
it's very nice to be here and actually
it's always helpful to me to know who
I'm speaking to I was talking to Joan
beforehand and I understand you're
mostly or how many are yall students
know ok so we have some faculty as well
so in terms of students what's the
backgrounds are we clinicians after
commission raise your hand researchers
ok engineers other lawyers oh I guess
usually watch my lawyer jokes ok good
well yeah so I am a faculty member
university massachusetts
school and I've got this very
interesting I was very involved I've
known bill for many years and I got
involved in health information
technology about ten years ago when
Governor Romney was planning his first
run for president and he said you know
he thought it's been running for Jeb but
run against Jeb Bush and Jeb Bush had a
state a chai tea plan and so he turned
to us at the University to write a state
a chai tea plan so he could you know say
he was doing something this is at the
same time he was working on health
reform anyhow so we got involved in a
chai tea at that point at the University
and sorry the question that the governor
was asking as well where should we make
investments is it appropriate for the
government to make an investment and we
found that the most appropriate place
for the governor to make investment was
for the Medicaid program and we did a
series of projects funded by AHRQ
looking about what the role the Medicaid
program could be should be in electronic
medical records and hie and I'm you know
that as many of you who've studied the
HITECH Act and a part of what got
written into high tech deck with
specific incentives recognizing the
value of the Medicaid program and the
importance of Medicaid program providers
to be incentivized to participate as
well subsequent to that I got an agate
asked by the the new governor when when
h aight when the AC a pass to its if the
university could help massachusetts
upgrade its systems to build the
information technology for health care
reform and that's what Russell are we
talking about a fair amount today and
you know I understand from Joan that you
really have not had that much exposure
necessarily to H IX you know the other
exchange and you know what we'd like to
do is give you an update about the
overall concept the role of health
insurance exchanges talk about the
information technology and the data
that's relate to building those things
and use specific examples from the two
of the you know two of the leading
states or again in Massachusetts about
what we're doing and how we're thinking
about this and then end by coming back
and saying well what does this mean for
you as in fermentations of a future you
know how should informatics get involved
be involved be thinking about what
you're doing in terms of health reform
that sound like a good agenda so basic
Glee you know health insurance exchanges
hrx are the key central component of how
health reform how the ACA is being
implemented there you know and i'll talk
about the the coverage expansions and
the expectations and cost containment
but H I exes have a significant
responsibility with the private and the
public insurance market and one of the
most significant things as they are
going to become the primary means for
determining eligibility for Medicaid as
well as the subsidies that will become
available through the ACA and although
there's significant differences between
the ACA between you know we now are
comfortably calling Obamacare and the
Massachusetts reforms Romneycare you
know but she didn't ever owned totally
but there simply there are some major
differences and I'm going to quickly
sort of go through some of what we did
in Massachusetts in 2006 talked about
how things are different and then talk
about under under Romneycare and then
talk about the improvement the IT
infrastructure so chapter 58 2006 was
the mass so called Massachusetts health
reforms otherwise known affectionately
care it was fun you know you see that
Romney did in fact sign the bill and
that Senator Kennedy's smiling the
background senator I used to work on
senator staff and he said after this he
says you know if you see Romney and I
smiling while he's signing a bill you
know one of us hasn't read it and it's
one of one of my favorite quotes in the
senator but anyhow the basic content of
Massachusetts reform was there was an
expansion of Medicaid there was a
subsidized insurance coverage for
low-income adults that allow them to buy
commercial insurance and this is the
part that Romney really fought for and
there was a number of you know insurance
market reforms and the idea was they
were shared responsibilities is why
Romney was so excited about this wasn't
just a government expansion of Medicaid
programs everybody had to pay employers
individuals and government and it was
very very strong as you all know on the
individual mandate making sure because
that's what you needed to make this work
if you're going to keep the private
insurers in business and as
of that we set up something called the
Massachusetts Commonwealth connector
Authority otherwise known as the
connector or the Massachusetts exchange
and what this did is it's an independent
state agency it had two things people
know have probably heard how many have
heard about the connector and heard
about the basic concept of an exchange I
mean people know about the basic idea of
exchange it's like an online marketplace
it's amazon or travelocity for health
insurance you know and that is part of
it what the connector also had is some
some legislative had regulatory
authority about this determining what
makes a program a health program
affordable and it also had a lot of
authority about how to structure that
market and they that made decisions that
first of all the law required that there
be the subsidized program called
Commonwealth care and that's the best
most similar as you'll see later to the
advance tax credits part of the ACA a
part of Obamacare and Commonwealth
choice which is more the expedia
marketplace where we basically
structured insurance plans and made it
easier for consumers to make decisions
so the cut you know the current health
connector Webb Porter offers a
user-friendly shopping experience and if
you haven't been there you can log on
and a lot I've taken a lot of my friends
and family through this and it works
pretty well it's sort of
state-of-the-art 2007 website you know
in that you know you can enter you know
depending by who you are there's a
portal and if you're an individual or
family you know you have asked you a
couple simple questions to get you
started on the search you know you put
in your family size and then it does a
very quick back-end calculation about in
our case three hundred percent of
poverty and Massachusetts under the
performs and if you say that your income
is more than three hundred percent of
poverty then it collects a little bit
more information about where you live
you know whether you're looking for
yourself or your family and then it
allows you to search among you know
these plans you know that you know which
we made gold silver and bronze for the
ACA for Obamacare it's they've added a
platinum level but basically plans that
are grouped by similarities in their
actuarial actuarial value and
also similarities therefore in terms of
what's covered in each of those plans
and then once you make a selection you
get to see the plans and you have the
plans you know presented in a somewhat
standardized fashion and this was really
something up to up to then you know you
could go to a blue cross blue shield
website or an aetna website but you
could not see plans on the same shelf
that were compared in standardized ways
and then you can see within there's
there's within the bronze you know plans
in this case there's multiple plans
level there's multiple plans available
that vary by their deductibles by
out-of-pocket expenses you know generic
drugs are handled things like this and
then like other shopping sites common
around that time you could select
different plans and compare them draw
them out of course all Massachusetts
plans are above average you know because
you know I don't ncqa sort of likes us
there but so that quality ratings
weren't that helpful but you can learn a
little bit more about what's in the
packages and then you can go on in
detail you know get more details and
you'll see even in this in this bronze
standardized plan that one of the plans
has a premium only two hundred forty
dollars a month another plan has a
premium of three hundred eighty dollars
a month and not surprisingly people ten
when they're presented this way to go to
lower-cost plans this is one of the
ideas of how you save money and they're
very very standardized in terms of what
the benefits are so this is actually
pretty comfortable the trick is for most
people it seems that most people make
their decisions now on how much it costs
what's a monthly premium which is not
necessarily the lowest cost and that's
that's a conversation we might get into
and is whether they're doctors in the
plan so we also have a plan a doctor
finder to make sure that the plan you're
signing up for so this is the connector
currently now that was for the
unsubsidized expedia experience first so
any questions about that you know that's
sort of the standardized the marketplace
approach yes
got to plan the same benefits but i'd
assume a different panel yes cost dipper
by a factor of two yes factor of yeah
whatever the math is there one for ya
yeah well it's actually not that was
like 230 to 380 yeah right that's right
that's right very similar so interesting
isn't that so now you would not have
known that because you couldn't have you
couldn't have shopped that any other way
and so and we've found that it has made
a big difference and it has affected the
plans so plans submit their there's a
whole process that the connector goes
through of saying here's here's how the
standardized benefits we're looking at
all the plans put in then and then they
say oh my god we're way out you see them
changing prices if they want to builder
the panel yes done so what we actually
did you get from blue cross blue shield
of massachusetts when this came out
what's that what was the reaction from
blue cross blue shield of massachusetts
it's a really plan well they well the
thing is you know some questions whether
they wanted to you know that this may
have been a strategic on their part that
they really didn't want to get in this
business you know that this wasn't now
it's going to change with the ACA you
know because blue cross blue shield is
already like many Blue Cross officials
fairly dominant plan in the state and
they were a little uncertain about who's
going to be coming through they were
afraid of being selected against
risk-averse you know so they actually
may have priced their plan purposely
high because they weren't trying to grow
and there's a whole conversation about
that that has implications Ashley as
well okay so now what happens if let's
say that the family goes a little
different way and this is to show how
the current subsidized plans work so if
you need insurance let's get started you
start now you put in your family size of
four and in this case you say no I
income is not above sixty nine thousand
which is 300 sent of poverty for family
for in Massachusetts at the time the
screen shot was taken what happens in
well then you're gone you're sent to a
page which really tells you basically
you know go find out about this go to an
enrollment worker and you referred to a
paper process which would be more the
more traditional Medicaid eligibility
process but anybody here worked or
familiar with Medicaid is Medicaid a
core subject here okay so you know them
if you're not going to Medicaid it's you
know it's a great program in terms of
very broad benefits it's you know
good here in Oregon but the process of
eligibility is very complicated there's
a lot of categorical eligibility you
know you could be you have two families
who have the same income and one has a
disabled child and they get medicaid in
this family doesn't you could have one
that you know is some is pregnant they
get it but the innocents are off
pregnancy don't get so it's very very
complicated and often discontinuous
people get rolled and destroyed a lot so
and there's this pay process and one of
the major actually i'll come back to
that point so this is one of the
limitations of the Massachusetts reforms
in this case you would go to the paper
process and it might be found well if
you're between a hundred and fifty
percent and fifty and 300 center poverty
and you didn't have any of their
Medicaid qualified conditions you'd be
eligible for the subsidized program code
Commonwealth care if you were below 133
and you were you know al papa papa you
might get into the Medicaid program but
it certainly wasn't an instantaneous
determination nevertheless Massachusetts
as you know as most people know you know
was was very successful and what they
intended to do which was to get you know
close to universal coverage there are
over four and a thousand people who
didn't have insurance before do you have
insurance ninety-eight percent of folks
in Massachusetts have insurance there is
it you know one of the things I drove
this made it successful was the
individual mandate because people if you
don't have insurance and you don't have
a 1099 HC 1099 health care that you put
in with your with your in it taxes each
year then you're going to be dinged on
your insurer and you have to pay
additional taxes and in Massachusetts
it's pegged at the you know that about
half the cost of what the lowest-cost
plan available to you would be so most
people make the deduction with chief are
going to pay hat could spend you know
fifteen hundred dollars to get nothing
why not just spend three thousand
dollars and get myself but you know a
inexpensive health insurance plan you
know public supporters say it's strong
you know that we didn't fall off the
cliff you know most employers actually
think it worked well it's very it's been
a very well-received thing we're not any
more socialistic than we were before
this you know we were Massachusetts we
were like the West East the west coast
of Oregon so now the cost of health care
and the
rate of increase in health care spending
remains a challenge and you may have
seen in Kaiser today they just announced
the new health care cost containment
input you know Commission in
Massachusetts you know it was never
designed similar to Obamacare to really
have very strong cost containment the
idea was to expand coverage so that was
Massachusetts 2006 reforms now very
similar signing ceremony senator Kennedy
wasn't here for this one you don't see a
lot of bipartisan folks you know at this
one I don't know if there's a Republican
who would allow their picture to be
taken on this day but you know it was
with a lot of fanfare and the basic the
basic structure is the same as
Massachusetts you have a Medicaid
expansion subsidized insurance
implementation of insurance market
reforms and there is this concept of
shared responsibility so very similar in
that context however there are
differences and I'll talk about some of
the similarities so the Medicaid
expansion here goes to 133 percent of
the federal poverty level and it's
anticipated am i speaking too quickly
okay it's anticipated that about 16
million people will become eligible if
States fully implement the expansion as
it as the law is written another eight
million people will wind up getting
insurance through subsidized purchase
and this is going through this is the
part that's different than Massachusetts
in Massachusetts we reported at the end
of the year we have 200,000 people
receiving subsidized care we gave a bill
the government they gave they paid us
back it was done under Medicaid Waiver
the difference here is a subsidized
purchase is going to be through advanced
premium tax credits which functions
similar to the Earned Income Tax Credit
so that now doing this it's a it's it's
it's a basically very core republican
idea that the Heritage Foundation has
been pushing since 1990 and they forgot
about it after they got the log i passed
but this is a republican health plan a
way of allowing poor people allowing the
insurance companies to exist but
allowing people who are less well off to
buy insurance with advanced well tax
credits this is will come back this
because this is one of the major
complexities of the technology
and its really it's interesting
opportunity but there's a lot of
challenges in rustling I'll both talk
about that and then you know then
there's the with the equivalent of
Commonwealth choice this expedia
marketplace will allow intervention
competitive insurance through an
insurance exchange hopefully that
structures the experience so that it's
simple for people to make decisions and
there's additional business tax credits
promote businesses to continue to
support health insurance so this whole
thing got very distorted during the
during a thing you know you have got
these two twins you know the Obamacare
Romneycare mommy saying your kid is ugly
but you know I mean you know it's sort
of like they have the same genes you
know the same core but because of the
nature of making this federal it does
make it more complicated so kids look
similar in many ways so one of the one
of the most interesting that in there's
a lot to the technology and I'm just
going to focus on a few of things few
things is to bring out enough so we can
have the conversation about where
informatics fits in this but you know
what the expectation is for the
technology here is that there be a
first-class user experience instead of
having to go into a Medicaid caseworkers
office and you know bring in your all
your tent your tax returns and your wage
slips that people can actually you know
make make have the insurance purchase be
a little less owners owners owners
onerous and having a single streamline
eligibility form so it doesn't matter so
if you're applying for any kind of
government support have it single single
not just for health insurance
interesting enough but actually making
this and Russell talk about this
potentially an entry for all health and
human services and modernizing that
whole system and really one of the most
critical differences and I think one of
those challenging things as the
exchanges are required to determine
eligibility for and coordinate
enrollment for Medicaid this is a very
very big change so you have these
organizations which don't yet exist in
most states and it's just Massachusetts
that has an existing exchange all of a
sudden taking over responsibility for
eligibility and enrollment for this
long-standing very large
no a very complicated program and this
is where a lot of states are stumbling
right now so and I'll just make one more
general point you know because my son is
a computer scientist and when he heard
that you know I was the p.i on a 45
million dollar grant to build a website
which is what it was originally reported
as he said with gee dad could you just
give me you know case of diet dr. pepper
and $5,000 get my friends get will have
a hackathon and build this thing over
the weekend and I I said that's kind of
good but you know then I sent in this
slide to show just one component of it
so of what's involved in a technology
when so it I think the stack on that
what I guess is on your left shows
things that are happening in the state
the stack in the middle is something
that doesn't yet exist which the federal
government is currently building called
a data services hub and the stack on the
right is the different federal databases
that have to be involved so when someone
comes in to shop at the at the exchange
and we'll look over on your before they
even shop there's all these things have
to be recorded in terms of what is
considered to be a qualified health plan
you can offer because of the insurance
market reforms you have to offer
qualified health plan which offer the
essential health benefits that are
mandated by the law and and tailored to
each individual state so you have to
have benefit plan data load in advance
then someone comes in the shop the first
thing that has to happen you have to
validate who they are so there'll be a
social security validation request and
response that will go to the federal
data services hub go to SS a for a
response and these are happening
simultaneously you know the law as
written will require certification of
citizenship you can't you can't even you
can't shop on exchange of you're not a
citizen so that that involves Homeland
Security you know you know their
databases are pretty open of course
right and citizen verification SS a then
there's a whole income verification
process that has to happen where people
self a test or their their data their
their their income but a lot of people
don't know what their I mean how many
people here know what their modified
adjusted
saincome was for last year you know I
mean you know you and let you know you
it's not obvious actually there isn't a
particular space that says what's your
family modified just as gross income
because modified by what so we have a
there's a system that's being built
where it a little typo into I think it's
16 different IRS IRS databases to give
the response well yes this person Joe
Nash dr. Ashe you are you know your
modified just gross income as X and
therefore you are eligible for going
shopping probably you can just go shop
but some of your students may maybe tell
well you could you may be eligible for
an advance premium tax credit and in
that case you know there's a you also
have to verify whether you currently
have insurance and then there's this
whole thing of calculating your advance
premium tax rate best based off of your
of your your modified adjusted gross
income you get a response back and then
we can go shopping okay so then so that
so it's a little more complicated than
you can do in a hackathon in the weekend
and very dependent on these other
systems being built and having service
level agreements that can give you the
information quick enough so you don't
lose she don't time out on people so now
we can start shopping so you can see
it's a little more complicated than
connector one point 0 and then you know
people who presented the data in a way
that says so getting back to the First's
I just showed you in the connector
instead of a health plan costing you
what was that the cheapest one was was
240 you might be eligible for tax credit
of I'll just make up the number forty
dollars a month so that only for you
might only be two hundred dollars a
month and likewise boo cost with shield
would instead of being 380 would be 340
you know so it makes a plans cheaper but
doesn't make up for the differences in
in there things you wouldn't get paid
more you wouldn't get more practice
credit for choosing a higher plan okay
so any i won't i won't kill you with
this but one of the challenges that you
know Russell probably talking about in
order to do this you know the states
will also have to be hitting on other
data sources within the state often
which are legacy systems which aren't
really that you know set up necessary to
give very quick responses so on wage
data employment data family data you
know
so so in order to make this system work
you know states need to create or have
access to a web portal seems fairly
straightforward but the secure
interfaces with the federal data
services hubs state data sources and
health plan carriers and they need to
make major upgrades their Medicaid
systems to be able to send and receive
eligibility information from the state h
IX to the federal data services hub so
before I I'm going to transition to
politics for a second here but any any
questions about the general idea of what
we're what what the new exchanges are
required to do technology wise we are
everybody with me still right pace okay
and actually rust collaborated with us
but I have some you know we recently did
you know there's four states that were
given money to you know get a jump start
on the technology oregon and
massachusetts new york and maryland
they're all working on this and this the
the handout that I've brought shows a
paper we did for the national academy of
social insurance which talks about what
some of the early lessons of those
states who've been trying to build this
and you know there's also there's a
health affairs blog about as well that
you might find interesting okay so we
had an election last week had one in who
won in oregon i think obama won in
oregon right so you know there's a lot
there's a lot as you know a lot of
politics i don't think did they carry
fox news out here you know you know in
the eastern mountains at you just
thought but you know you would have
known it from fox news i mean you know
that you know that you know the obama
was i have time forced to watch it when
i'm working out at the gym you know
because it's 13 of the six channels
unfortunately and you know you think
that you know master said falling off
the cliff and you know obama was a Nazi
socialist and if we did this you know
life on earth would end and stuff like
that but turns out and the complications
of all the politics of health of first
with the individual mandate mishegoss
and the and the election a lot of states
have been a lot of states that have
slowed their development you know
assuming the law was going to go away
hoping that Obama wouldn't be reelected
or some like that and also it has slowed
because of the politics of it some of
the work
and distracted the pork on the on the
federal so you're going to see a lot now
happening to really accelerate
implementation because the you know some
of some of ACA Obamacare has already
been implemented you know that over the
children's being able to seeing their
family plan and you know probably
someone you know the high-risk insurance
plan you know you may know people who
have been affected by this already but
the major changes happen in 2014 when
the health insurance exchanges go alive
and when the Medicaid expansion you know
is fully implemented so they've got to
really accelerate their work on ACA
regulations and an implementation and
you know they've got their own big
challenge to build they've got to build
this federal data services hub which is
fairly complex has never been done
before the IRS is really not that
familiar with having you know other
people sort of querying their their data
and there's all kinds of special rules
that we're learning about in terms of
excuse me security for that kind of data
and also i'll talk a little bit about
this you know there is this thing called
the federally facilitated exchange which
was intended as a really as a threat you
know because we want to make sure as a
threat you know for those states they
couldn't get it together you know there
might be a few states that we're laggard
states or didn't have the technology
support but you want to make sure that
people in those states would be able to
get access to the benefits of the ACA so
there is this in this in this in the law
there's this possibility for federal
facilitate exchange but what's happened
because of all the delays from you know
mostly the red state Republican related
states there may be quite a few states
that are going to have to be on the
federal exchange and that's quite a
complicated build for the feds to do so
those are some things that they have to
worry about on the state side and we'll
talk next about that I apologize you
know the states now are really going
into full gear and we'll both talk about
that but the readiness and willingness
to do the implementation really varies
tremendously and one of the biggest
challenges because it has one of the
longest hot lines as building a
technology to support this there's
also a lot of other things we're not
going to talk about much today about the
policies that have to be made the
decision about how active a purchaser
the exchange is going to be you know how
generous you're going to be with your
Medicaid expansions that you have new
flexibility if there's a lot of other
things but the technology bill takes a
fair amount of time especially
connecting to these old legacy systems
and craig nooks and new new interfaces
to systems that don't yet exist so the
post-election landscape this is the this
is the election night map for it I guess
eventually came around to be a blue
state but you'll see this was as of
election night you know the state the
stars of the states that have have put
in their so-called blueprint and are
planning to have their exchanges up and
running by january fourteenth and you'll
see there's about 12 states here there's
been a couple more that have come on in
the last week Secretary Sebelius on
Friday extended deadline for another
couple weeks for states to declare but
probably there won't be many more than
15 states that are gonna be ready on
january2014 to plant exchange so there's
a whole other conversation or what
happens to the rest of the states but
what what the what the feds have come up
with is a transition plan so on the left
side of your screen you have states like
Oregon to Massachusetts will be a
state-based exchange and they'll
basically do all the things I talked
about with connector one point 0 plus
some additional things and they'll be
operating their own state exchange which
includes they'll have control of their
Medicaid program they'll have control
over the insurance market another
extreme we have the 25 to 30 you know
Republican governors who really are
still dragging their feet and we're
probably going to have to default to the
federal exchange and that's going to be
very interesting conversation over the
next couple months and we'll see if that
changes in the middle you have a bunch
of states that really you know weren't
the early innovators they you know they
would like to do their own state based
exchange some of the red states like to
exchange they don't like the idea the
federal government running these things
for them and the state the feds are
offering them as a state partnership
where the law initially the technology
and other support may come from the feds
with a plan for them to transition in
twenty fifteen or twenty sixteen for
their own exchange
so you know it's been it's been a long
and winding journey you know you know
Congress that you know the lot of folks
Congress is going to stop at the state
courts will stop at the stream court
will stop it president Romney will stop
it and here we go you know the answer
stop it and decide so now we're really
at a decision point for the country and
for a lot of those governments I'm sorry
question oh they count on your previous
slide you talked about states may
determine Medicaid and CHIP eligibility
that's a pretty big thing to do the
interface how's that going to work in
which one in which column we're looking
at looking at the bottom of second and
third columns yep right so this means
they have to set up a database of who's
eligible or how does that yeah well
that's a whole other conversation and
maybe let's come back to at the end but
yeah I mean that's the thing it's not
it's not nothing you know say okay will
do this what what the feds are saying is
will help you determine the federal
eligibility will make these interfaces
to the federal hub will give you the
information about your the modified
adjusted gross income and then we'll
refer people who we think are eligible
for Medicaid program and then states can
you know states can focus on me one way
of thinking about this might allow those
states who can't do the whole thing just
to focus on getting their Medicaid
program of the stuff the encouraging
thing is you know I said there's only 12
or 13 states that are going full-bore to
like Oregon and Massachusetts rebuilding
in a single system their exchange and
they're in what we call integrated
eligibility system for Medicaid over 40
states have applied for it have gotten
money from the feds to upgrade their
Medicaid eligibility systems so that's
going to happen I want to get one of the
question here
say one other question yeah so for those
states that have declared we're not
doing it is there anything different you
know when there's a the
federally-facilitated they'll be on the
federally facilitated exchange what's
the impact of their citizens it's going
to be very it's going to be really it
could be very messy could be very messy
I mean there's rust pointed out I mean
they already run their Medicaid programs
the Supreme Court you know complicated
things Justice Roberts the variance in
in in in parsing the baby and it's a
fairly technical thing that vlado to
understand he he did validate the the
individual you know mandate which was a
you know core of what the Supreme Court
vet but they did they did they did allow
states and I think a lot of the
Republican states may be in this not to
expand all the way two hundred thirty
three percent so you could have the
situation where people are eligible for
tax credits if they're build one hundred
thirty three percent but if they're blow
one thirty three percent you know the
state has in between you know and that
could be very really vary from state to
state they may be sort of lost you know
so instead of 16 million people becoming
eligible for Medicaid it maybe 10 or 12
in a dependent how states choose to do
that they made it a sweetened the pie to
encourage States to do this but some
states still are just you know operating
on the principle of know so I think I
think what I might do is I want to make
sure Russ has enough time to talk i'm
just going really quickly go you know
what there's there's a conversation in
my in the in the white paper here about
you know the potential for reusability
things that we're doing in Oregon and
Massachusetts which might be helpful to
accelerate the development other states
I don't think i'll talk about that i'll
just do a very quick sense of you know
what this means in massachusetts and
handed over to to to russ you know so
what we're doing in the areas in blue
here are the new technologies that we're
building on top of the legacy systems
that are on the right okay so legacy
systems you know you don't know neither
different no details but the mmm i asked
the medicaid management information
system is the system that typically does
medicaid enrollments and manages claims
payments so we're not replacing that
right away we're connecting to
legacy systems and the things in blue
are things that we're building which we
think have the potential to be reused by
other states either in part by the you
know the architectural design and the
documentation or depending if they've
got compatible platforms compatible
software compatible legacy systems
potentially it could be you know hosted
across several states so the things in
blue represent those things and I'll
just draw out a couple things you know
all these systems where I need to have
very interesting master data management
systems where you can identify someone
who's coming in you'll have to know what
we found out about their income and
their their their preferences will have
to know what plan their they're enrolled
in and one of the things to be thinking
about well and we'll have to have some
unique identifiers how does that
potentially relate to some of the things
you're wonder about in informatics how
can that information be connected with
other things that you're thinking about
and you know the idea being that some of
these core things you know that we've
developed a portal and the rules engines
and the data management systems could be
eventually made available to other
states in what we call it tier two
sharing example or in theory and I say
it's a theory because it gets very
complex and details you could have a
multi-tenant hosted solution where what
we build in Massachusetts if we find a
state that really likes what we did once
to basically use that you know leverage
the interfaces we've built you know we
could have we could have a mirror of
that made and have it another state
operate within the same cloud they would
still have to manage through and
Medicaid in this particular example
manager and Medicaid and CHIP programs
and tying with their own legacy system
so that may be a way of accelerating
things so I think what I want to do is I
would hand it over to Russ to talk about
more suppose he's a technology I am just
a simple country doctor so you can talk
a little bit what you know what from
Boston what what they're doing an Oregon
and then we can open it back to
discussion Thank you Thank You Jay I do
not have as many degrees as Jay and I
cannot speak as quickly I don't know
that's necessarily correlated I wanted
to know before I started how many people
are actually from Oregon I mean
many people live here now or have lip
some but it's a minority okay so the
first thing i want to emphasize is with
that technology slide that Jay had with
all of the lines showing how complicated
it is it is so much more complicated in
that I could I was biting my tongue all
the way through not to jump up and down
it and say hey it's I mean before you
even authenticate anyone onto the system
and we saw that little arrow going up to
the social security number how do I know
you're you right and you know today if
you're doing this commercial if you're
going to go on Amazon the way they know
you're you is that you got those three
digits on the back of your credit card
number that's all you care about it's a
valid use of the credit card that's
that's to them knowing that you are you
if you're a human service or a medical
service or organization like Medicaid
today the way we know you're you is you
come down to the office we look at your
people your wallet outlook your driver's
license a few other things ah that's how
we know you're you how are we going to
know your you here going up to the
social security number and saying well
yeah the one he entered matches the name
yet that's not enough so it's way way
more complicated so Oregon started on
this journey very early we were one of
the early innovator States so called
because a number of grants were given
away before the establishment grants
came online in order to get some states
out in front so that they could
demonstrate and perhaps develop
artifacts that could be reused and it's
an important part of Oregon's
responsibility to promote reuse and I've
been doing that as much as I can I
wanted to say that we started right at
the end of 2010 so we got started on
this very early we were able to leverage
some procurements we already had in the
pipe and so at this point in time I'm
showing you screenshots that probably
few states can show you other than
Massachusetts this is this is the actual
Oregon connector
which is largely built although not
completely built and one of the things
that really isn't done at this point is
one of the hardest pieces of heavy
lifting the integration all of that all
those other systems that need to be
included particularly the integration
back to legacy so that is one of the
major challenges still facing us but we
do have all of those compared plan and
search and so forth screens similar to
what Jay was showing you but their 2012
not twenty two thousand six so what is
what is Oregon um if for the purpose of
health insurance exchange it's a
middle-sized state in terms of
population today most people as in every
other state get their health insurance
from their employer there's another
quarter of a million that get their own
individual health insurance there's a
little over half a million on Medicaid
and Medicare and then there's a little
over half a million that are uninsured
so and that's really similar to the rest
of the nation so that's the the
breakdown of the population today and
we're a little simpler than most states
in terms of the number of carriers
there's over ninety percent of this
population is served by only seven
carriers which is really good from our
point of view in running the health
insurance exchange project we only need
to get lately it's been around 12 13
carriers in the room to have a meeting
with everyone to be able to talk actual
face-to-face personal conversations with
CIOs from each of these carriers that's
a luxury that states with a couple
hundred carriers that are eligible to
for medical coverage in their state they
can't do that and the carrier
integration is one of the biggest
challenge is not the biggest but it's
one of the big challenges so if you if
you look at the health insurance
exchange as as Jay explained comprising
both qualified health plans from private
carriers and public offerings that are
based in
Medicaid where how much do we expect to
enroll through that exchange and where
are they going to come from so we expect
that the Medicaid expansion will bring
on at least another 225,000 people this
is a highly guarded number at the agency
i work at so i wanted to show more
aggressive projections but this is the
projection that that that were
comfortable with and we we expect more
than that to come in and select
qualified health plans through the
health insurance exchange and so this is
the combined enrollment that will happen
by 2015 through the health insurance
exchange in Oregon according to our
projections and we expect that these
people are going to come from
twenty-five percent from the current
individual market forty percent from
current small group and twenty-two
percent from uninsured so it'll drain
that uninsured pool somewhat i wanted to
talk a little bit about the structure
this might not seem like an informatics
problem but when you graduate and go to
actually implement these things it's
actually not so hard to get the bits in
the computer to line up as it is to get
the people and the different entities
they represent to line up and so Oregon
is similar to other states in that
there's four major players in the
state's the health insurance exchange
itself will be run by a public
corporation that's been established by
our legislature and has been convened it
has its own board that doesn't report
directly to the agency or to the
governor of its public corporation
similar to pers if you're familiar with
the Oregon retirement system we have two
major state geez that wasn't even a joke
or maybe it was uh I don't want to touch
that one two major agencies involved
here the Oregon Health Authority
obviously which is the agency that sets
Medicaid
see and it's the agency that wrote the
early innovator grant and kicked off the
health insurance exchange work here in
the state and the department of human
services because for lots of medicaid
it's uh it will still be done in field
offices it does if you're
developmentally disabled for example
still require a personal face-to-face
contact so some medicaid will not be
able to only have the online experience
all the way through to enrollment so it
also involves the Department of Human
Services and there's also the Oregon
insurance division so you've got to get
all of those people move in the same way
think in the same way and then there's
also the legislature and also the feds
fortunately in Oregon we have great
partnership and our championing of
health insurance exchange goes way back
before the ACA in 2007 the Oregon
Legislature asked what was at that time
the department of human services to
prepare a health insurance exchange plan
so I way back at the end of 2007 so our
strategy as I mentioned we got an early
start because we were able to leverage
an existing procurement that the
Department of Human Services was doing
and it wasn't even aimed primarily at
Medicaid it was aimed at all the other
human services as well as Medicaid snap
Kenneth all the employment related stuff
and and so forth that the state agency
does so fortunately their strategy was
to use a commercial off-the-shelf
product and because that product was off
the shelf it was robust what normally
happens in states is we build custom
solutions or we bring in a custom
solution that another state built and
that's called the transfer solution if
you build a custom solution yourself and
if you get the requirements write and
execute correctly you can wind up with a
nice solution it's not likely to be
reusable in another area it was built
customized just for that one area
that you targeted even more limiting if
you brought in a transfer solution
because that was customized for some
other state which hopefully is similar
because we bought an off-the-shelf
product it was actually pretty easy to
extend it from the human services that
were targeting the procurement to we
were able to piggyback on that and move
it over to to be efficacious for health
insurance exchange too and so we we felt
that the products were ripe enough that
you didn't need a commercial solution
that the advantage of having a whole
company invested in evolving that
solution were really significant
compared with having to evolve it with
what the best we could do with state
employees and this is one of the most
serious challenges that a state faces
with any of these solutions if you build
it yourself you'll get the money to do
that once you won't get the money or the
resources to keep it up and so that the
stuff comes very out of date so that was
why we went in in this particular
direction now our vision ah is to not
only use it for health insurance
exchange I want to try and introduce a
different idea of reuse here see the
idea we had around reuse wasn't so much
carving off the health insurance
exchange piece just the medical piece
and then trying to share that across
states that's certainly a valid reuse
model instead we wanted to implement
this technology and then reuse it across
both agencies reuse it across all these
different health and human services that
the state has to determine eligibility
for to manage enrollment in and to be
able to use analytics across all of that
data because they are so similar it's
the same family that's on snap that's on
Medicaid as an example and so forth so
are our vision of reuse was to implement
it up across this the scope of both of
these agencies but there will be
different experiences so if you go in
through the health insurance
exchange portal it'll be like what I
showed you in the beginning not only
will it be all about medical and only
medical but it'll be a shopping
experience and the people involved in
that experience are very concerned that
it doesn't look like a government
offering you know that's not the
population they're targeting and a lot
of the population they're targeting
doesn't want it to feel like a
government thing they want it to feel
more like Amazon and so you'll see that
type of user experience here if you go
in over here the department of human
services that is operating this portal
is much more concerned with determining
all the benefits you might be eligible
for then they are about just getting you
medical and so they're unabashedly going
to talk to you about all these
government benefits that you might be
eligible for and so the experiences will
be different the neat thing is it's all
one system we went out and purchased an
integrated stack from oracle and so
regardless of which door you go through
as eligibility is being determined and
medical eligibility as an example will
be determined through either of these
doors it goes back to the same rules
engine oracle policy automation it
creates a case which has the same client
master so we we know who you are we can
bring in the data that you've already
entered last year yesterday or someone
else in your family entered so it's one
brain in that the logic is common and
the data are common change is there a is
there any connection I don't know how
organs health information exchange is
set up but is there any connection
between health and exchange in this and
where we are there similar kind of
client identifiers perfect segue to the
next slide was there another question
because I'm going to take that as an
opportunity to segue yes reiterate that
question
in that howdy what's your protocols for
patient identification mm-hmm or client
identificate ok so both questions are
really around data around in you know
information right so let's let's start
to talk about it so today if when it's
huge um I just did this last night so
I'm just becoming acquainted with it
myself so these are some of the system
areas i mean we actually have probably
400 systems that that comprise this
scope so i'm really simplifying it these
are not actual systems but their areas
that systems operate in and where there
are multiple systems today friend take
and eligibility I've tried to show that
as a fractured line so the blue ones are
new ones that we're building though it
exists yet the brown or ones that are
already in so ah we do medical intake
and eligibility in a number of disparate
systems we do a human service intake and
eligibility in different disparate
siloed systems we have implemented our
to get back to your question our health
information exchange just this summer
and that is a rather rudimentary health
information exchange but it does include
a provider master and of course it
includes the exchange of health
information but it's it's an indirect if
you know what that is so it's really a
lot like secure email it's not a look up
a record locator type system at all in
fact there's no storage of health data
in this system the only data that are
stored is the provider master the
directory and so on I think the point I
wanted to make with a slide and looking
at the time unless there's a specific
question is how it will change so each
one of those buckets in those areas even
within that area like I showed
eligibility and I had those fractured
lines you can't get a view of a client
across the ER dc-10
snap and medical those are four
different system areas you can't easily
see across those areas you can't get a
360 degree view of a client partly
because the case and eligibility
information are in disparate systems but
also because we don't have the master
data management the client master itself
isn't able to come up with a unique
instance of a person that problem will
be solved over time a number of phased
implementations and by the way when the
health insurance exchange goes live
that's the door on the left and the
house I showed you earlier this one this
will also go live either at the same
time or before it's currently scheduled
to go live before so very aggressive
compared with what other states are
doing most states are racing as fast as
they can as Jay explain just to hit the
date and get this thing in we're
actually started at the same time with
both of these so we've doubled the race
because this is implementing not only
medical but in the initial release it
will also do snap and this is currently
scheduled to go life a little bit
earlier over time though over the next
let's say five years we will build out
these client portals all medical all the
qualified health plan for medical it's
only eligibility the enrollment and the
payment that's what your mmm is system
does not sure if we're moving that on to
this platform but all of these other
areas across all the human services
including medical will all be aggregated
into one system one database with one
client master and that's great because
now we will be able to get much more out
of our analytics we still have some
disparate systems there's of course the
all pair all claims system is is
different it has different data there's
a whole number of public health systems
that will probably remain different for
a number of reasons I could go into
interested and it's not clear that we
get to one provider master either
so exactly i think that one of the
things i think is in the discussion but
I want to just sort of close with a
couple thoughts and then a couple
questions so what r us has started to
introduce here as you know it the
feeling is that there's this huge
government investment you all know that
our in the high-tech billions of dollars
are there you know there's already over
a billion dollars it's been committed to
building you know that's a billion yeah
several billion dollars and we committed
to to building the health insurance
exchange infrastructure and we didn't
talk about it today but the all pair
claims databases and i think it's called
all payer all claims here in oregon is
something else that states are making
big investments in because that's
essential in order to mount it to manage
the reinsurance and the risk adjustment
systems that all states will have to
have to make these insurance
marketplaces work so these huge
investments being made and you know one
thing I'd like to you know whenever I
talk to an academic audience I like them
to be thinking about is you no are you
no are we what can we be doing to sort
of leverage this data I know you folks
do some really well great stuff mining
the epic emrs and stuff like that you
know it and I imagine some people are
thinking about if you really had a true
you know centralized database or some
way of calling out for statewide EHR so
people move out of Kaiser there's
somewhere else and you don't lose them
and you you know and there go out of the
Kaiser system you know you know more
complete what do they think about the
analytic possible informatica possible
so we leverage all these investments I
mean that and that's something I think
that we need leadership from you know
academic leaders like yourselves about
what could be done and how people like
you know Russ and I should be thinking
about the builds that we're making these
big investments so I think I think we
have two minutes left so I'll just
closer these are some questions we can
talk about but you know what do you all
think about the role bioinformatics you
know nhi action health reform what are
the implications for data you know for
research and how we offer how we operate
how do we take advantage while these
investments I think I'll end here and
should I take one or two questions or
should I end and then stay around for
people afterwards
okay any any any questions that people
have about this or thoughts I actually
been watching your thoughts I don't know
if I have any answers so yes go ahead
i'll just say that i kept looking at
this and thinking about the universal
identifier yes and seems like we're
creating another system to be disparate
from the health information exchange
once we try to get to that and I know
that we've kind of talked about this and
this isn't really a question but it just
seems to me why are we not and I know
that there's government have you studied
that whole thing I mean why isn't there
that must be a constant issue for your
EMR sub why Arthur universal and
identifiers I mean I think there was a
law once that was passed a great
Universal identifier who got taken back
right ya SE tu duc segment it but you
can't do it yeah what's the thought I
think you know I think what's happening
is a lot of very complex Oh workarounds
are happening you know I rust and I
didn't get to it today it's a whole
nother conversation how an IV
engineering how he's doing it in Oregon
but in Massachusetts how we're going to
go about client identifiers without
using you know that having a true
universal identifier and how you
validate who they are and you know
there's there's I guess there's a lot of
private systems that have been developed
as sort of without actually giving your
social security number figuring out high
likelihood that you are who you say you
are in this company's but unfortunately
it would be a lot you know from a
technology from an informatics point of
view wouldn't it be nice to have a
universal donor I think I think I'd
agree with you on that so I think what's
given the time why don't we stop here i
want to thank you for inviting us and
i'll be more than happy to stay around
for us for a few minutes as well thank
you very much